(dramatic music)
(siren wailing)
- So this is 119th Street,
the most violent area in our community.
- [Man] Sometimes it takes just one person
to confront the nation's biggest issues.
- [Woman] Homelessness.
- [woman] Immigration.
- [Woman] Gun violence.
- These are real problems
here in the United States,
and nobody else is paying
any attention to this.
- My main goals were to help these people.
When someone tells me no, I keep pushing.
- A small, little impact can
literally mean life or death.
- [Narrator] These five
women are defenders.
They're taking a stand, inciting action
and helping others in extraordinary ways.
- I've been doing this for 15
years, and I'm not stopping.